[Music]
the english premier league is
widely regarded as being home to the
very best soccer in the world
it's watched by billions across the
globe making it the richest too
and while soccer as we americans call it
isn't one of the top sports here in the
us it's
never seen so many american investors in
the uk
wait even american superheroes are
getting in on the action
hear the music could deadpool and
mack from always sunny really save the
day
us sports teams bring in a huge amount
of money for their owners
but if you want to buy into the nfl from
the dallas cowboys to the lowly
cleveland browns
sorry cleveland you probably need to be
a billionaire several times over
but for those who love what the rest of
the world calls football
buying into the english premier league
is way cheaper
and could give you a much better return
[Applause]
a billion plus people interact with the
epl
when you look at any american sport
there's nothing anywhere close to it it
just smelled of opportunity to me
while the huge investment in the epl is
intrinsically linked to the high quality
of the competition
and its star names big money talks
and it doesn't care much for history or
tradition
as radical plans to transform the game
have been revealed
u.s investors are increasingly viewed
with suspicion
but will these changes be for the good
of the game or just the wealthy owners
takes the snap drops back pumps once
looks right throws enzo
and the jets pad the lead it's 54-35
dover athletic nil northridge victoria
miller
[Music]
while our sporting sensibilities might
be drastically different
when it comes to sheer commercial
enterprise the
english premier league is right up there
the premier league's broadcast revenue
is more than
four billion dollars a season it's way
richer than the other european leagues
even the ones with global superstars
like messi ronaldo and neymar
and more of us in the states are tuning
in to at the expense of our own pro
soccer league
more than twice as many people watch epl
games than the mls
so how did english football become such
a hot deal for american investors
i needed an englishman to help me figure
this out all right so alex uh
educate me here like as an american
i'm intrigued but also a little bit
confused candidly by
english football so what are the main
differences especially
from the business perspective i mean
fundamentally in the us
uh you have a league system whereby
there are defined number of teams in the
league
revenues tend to be doled out a lot more
evenly between those teams obviously if
you finish a little bit higher at the
table you'll get a little bit more
in europe particularly in the uk you
have a league system
of four professional divisions and then
a number more amateur divisions and
theoretically if you or i set up an
amateur team
tomorrow we could inside a decade be
playing in the premier league it's
obviously in practice a lot
more difficult but by being promoted up
the tiers we could be
a premier league team at 11
30 precisely the game gets underway with
chelsea attacking
his left winger tommy knox working the
ball along across the harris then to
right winger murray
straight into the safe hands of england
and blackpool goalkeeper tony waiters
a lot of the history of these teams is
so baked into
the community maybe in a way that that
it isn't here in the united states
yeah when you look at the names of teams
actually you can see some of that you
think about a team like arsenal
it was actually the the team associated
with
the woolwich arsenal a military base
south of the river in london
with aston villa that's my team it was a
cricket team that
met up and said we want to stay fit
during the winter they met outside aston
villa
a villa in the birmingham suburb of
aston name their team after it
this is a massive business i mean the
reason that this
is attracting so much investment
ultimately is because
these team values have just skyrocketed
certainly
um in the epo yes and a lot of that is
to do with the
success in cultivating an international
audience the way that the premier league
in particular has really forged the lead
was in a sense by following what
happened in the u.s
in the early 90s they started doing
collective bargaining for their
broadcasting rights
used to be the case that if you were
manchester united or arsenal or
whichever club
might be you would individually
negotiate with the broadcaster
they said actually we're better off as a
unit if we all negotiate together
and that's when the premier league was
formed
you tied that up with the arrival of
rupert murdoch trying to bring
a satellite tv station to the uk
he recognized it was a huge amount of
passion for football
if he could lock up the rights for that
he would secure an audience for his pay
tv station
[Music]
live only on skype
now since the premier league was formed
we've seen a huge
ballooning in the valley of broadcast
rights it's jumped
60 folds since uh 1992. so previously
the value of the rights was about 600
000 pounds per game
in the most recent round it was at about
9 million per game
that is astonishing so with those sorts
of figures
it stands to reason that big investors
in the united states and elsewhere
would come calling and see a lot of
opportunity they've seen opportunities
for a bargain
you can buy a middling football club for
several hundred million you can buy a
football club in the second tier
for considerably less than that you
compare that to the nfl where
you know franchises change hands for
perhaps two billion dollars huge
difference then
[Applause]
the most famous us owners were the
glazers who owned the tampa bay
bucks they came in and bought manchester
united and they approached it
with the kind of attitude of a private
equity company you can pile a huge
amount of
debt onto it extract some of that um as
cash to line your own pockets and
because they are fundamentally media
assets you know it's quite resilient
as long as they invest enough in the
playing squad keep them in the champions
league you're going to be able to
generate enough free cash flow
to service your debt obligations
this is a couple of thousand quids with
the season tickets
the glazers aren't exactly loved in
manchester and to many british fans
they reflect the confusing emotions
inspired by us ownership
incredible financial growth might also
coincide
with declining sporting performance
but if you're looking for a model of
american ownership to follow
it might just be man united's biggest
rivals
liverpool the current champions have
enjoyed a resurgence in recent years and
that's happened since they were taken
over by fenway sports group
those are the guys behind the boston red
sox
an ownership group that knew what
success was about that knew how to build
um patiently uh everything that a
football club is about
this is peter moore he was the ceo of
liverpool when they won the champions
league in 2019
and then the premier league in 2020.
so peter what did fenway bring to
liverpool maybe something specific that
they brought
from running a very successful and very
fabled american baseball team
first thing that struck me when i spoke
with mike gordon is
he said we're not the owners of this
football club he said we have we have
the
economic rights to do business on behalf
of this football club
the owners of the fans
for me certainly there was no true
interference in in how we manage the
football club we improved the structure
of the football club they applied
science and data
all of the things that they'd learned
you know in the days of theo epstein and
young general managers
and brought in actual scientists and
data analysts
so that thousands of players were
analyzed that were in the marketplace
and our own players were analyzed to get
the best out of them
quick snap got protected in the pocket
but has to go underneath the ball comes
out
and the 49ers are on it one of the epl's
newest american execs comes with a deep
knowledge of american football
and a business acumen shaped by decades
in and around silicon valley
but he's the first to admit he's not a
soccer fan from the cradle
i started looking into soccer clubs
football clubs and
in europe gosh maybe 10 years ago at
that time
you know with all due respect i still
didn't know if a soccer ball was puffed
or stuffed
parag marate is the president of 49ers
enterprises
which bought a stake in leeds united in
2018
part of an ambitious effort by one of
america's storied franchises
to expand its portfolio at the time
leeds was itself a fabled franchise
but one that had fallen on hard times
leads were playing in the second
division of english football
last season they won promotion to the
top division the epo
[Music]
[Applause]
come on so tell me about promotion from
a business perspective because you're
doing a calculation here
about a huge potential upside you're
talking about
a 20x increase in per club media rights
uh from going from the championship to
the premier league you're still playing
in the same stadium with the same size
you know the same number of fans that
can come the same number of suites and
premium
but your media rights goes up 20-fold
promotion to the premier league
could be worth anywhere from 130 to 200
million pounds
just take this example in 2016 another
second division team
wolverhampton wanderers were bought for
around 63 million dollars
they gained promotion shortly after that
and are now estimated to be worth around
10 times that figure taking a punt
as they say in england on a team rising
up the divisions
can really pay off
but what goes up can also come down a
concept we americans aren't exactly
familiar with
two teams here who are desperate for
three points to avoid
relegation what are you looking forward
to well i'm looking forward to the
definition of relegation
three teams drop out of the premier
league every season
yes relegation is real and it's kind of
a doubt you have to manage the delicate
balance because there is a correlation
between between uh acquiring more
players in the transfer market and
buying players to be able to comp
to be more competitive um and and
winning and matriculating up the table
right
but at the same time that comes with a
risk because if you buy if you spend a
lot in the transfer market you get
relegated now all of a sudden
uh you're potentially more in a world of
hurt so yeah you do
you do have to factor that in and you do
have to model that one year ago
the club's valuation was much different
than it is today
right and trying to figure out okay well
which one is the real sustainable
valuation like that's a hard
exercise to do i hope for perrag and
leeds fans they don't drop anytime
soon the history of british football is
littered with stories of big time clubs
going down
and not making it back
but for many fans a relegation battle
can be just as exciting
as the chase for a championship
it's a very performance based system and
i'm sure there's probably some fans that
said wow i wish we had something like
that in america now i'm not suggesting
any owner wants that in america don't
get me wrong
alan pace and his u.s investment firm
alk capital
have also just joined the premier league
they've taken over burnley
a team just 50 kilometers away from
leeds in the north of england
we talk about performance-based stuff
all the time okay
we in in business and as entrepreneurs
and as other things
performance-based means you get rewarded
for performance
and so it's it seems kind of odd that
you wouldn't have it within your
you know your own sports process of look
if you don't perform
you don't get to stay with everybody
else but it's it's
also super interesting and i think very
cool
that people can get promoted and people
can get relegated based off of
performance
so alan as an investor what appeals to
you about the epl
you have a global audience that's just
very very different than any american
sport
i mean you're talking a billion plus
people interact with the epl and when
you look at any american sport there's
nothing anywhere close to it now i'm not
suggesting that you've monetized
that billion plus but if you just even
for you know a half a second think about
how could i monetize
that situation from a business
perspective you've got an
audience already it's like how do you
bring that capability and that knowledge
from
american sports into an audience that's
just that much bigger
and can you i mean that is a challenging
question for a lot of people is can you
actually do something with that and i i
honestly our bet is yes you can
what i have noticed about you know
football in europe versus kind of
american football and college is almost
very similar
that sense of community that sense of
passion
everybody coming together and really
kind of gelling for something a big
event
and so even though we're 30 40 minutes
outside of manchester
the whole community is a burnley fan
this is a relatively small town
everybody knows everyone
and certainly they know when an american
shows up
and buys the team what does that feel
like for you
well you know it's funny because there's
a lockdown
and so we haven't really got to meet a
lot of people so so no one's tried to
burn down my house yet and there's been
no pitchforks or anything
there's no reason to believe alk will
manage burnley badly
but it's the kind of leveraged
acquisition that can make fans nervous
and has previously resulted in major fan
protests
if i were burnley fan i'd be a little
bit just a little bit anxious
because you know there i was supporting
a club that was
earning 100 million a year from being in
the premier league broadcast income
had 40 million pounds in the bank um to
a club that now has quite
quite a high debt they're still in
relegation trouble this season
they could be in relegation travel with
most seasons and if they
are relegated then obviously their
broadcast income diminishes
by 20 times bernie could be relegated
and then
never come up again into the premier
league i mean there's a definite risk
with that
if you're buying a team in the premier
league the value of that team
is very closely tied to its on-field
performance and and that is just not the
case
in the us you'll you're de-risked um to
a great degree as a franchise owner in
the states because you know
if you have a poor year you'll get you
know top pick of the draft
that gives you um you know better
chances of improving your subsequent
years
you have one poor year in the premier
league and you're down a division
and losing a huge amount of revenue
teams adapt differently to relegation
but some just go straight down you know
they just can't cope it's like the whole
fiber of the club seems to collapse
so alan i've looked at the message
boards and it's fair to say
there's some skepticism out there
especially about the structure of the
deal
so from a layperson's perspective walk
me through it
the best analogy that i would give as to
what we've done is think about you've
seen
a house okay that you really like but
you think it's probably a little bit of
a fixer-upper
and you take a mortgage because it
actually makes sense with the process of
what you're doing
and then you can use some of your
capital more efficiently
in actually investing into the club in
different ways or fixing up the house in
different ways
yes there's leverage there's no doubt
about it because we any of any of us
that have ever had a home
or that have ever charged anything on a
credit on a credit card
there's leverage in our lives now if
burnley's a fixer-upper
this next club is one of the most
unlikely recipients of an american
makeover
and we're not talking about just any u.s
businessmen here
we're talking about a-listers ryan
reynolds and rob mcelhenny
wrexham are what's known as minnows
small fish in a big pond
in normal times they have an average
attendance of just 5
000 fans which is actually pretty good
for a team in the fifth division
last season they ranked 111th in the
football pyramid
so wrexham is a long way from that sweet
broadcast
revenue if you start in the bottom
you've got an
amazing upside of the possibilities of
promotion
ultimately they i think are looking for
a story
to be able to tell ryan reynolds and rob
mcelhenny it looks like they're
seeking a vehicle for a narrative and
ideally that narrative is get the team
promoted
up the divisions and that would make for
a pretty compelling
show on netflix or amazon prime or
wherever it might land
that team has not got a huge amount of
revenue um only
sort of two or three million pounds a
year if you're looking at a netflix show
which you're selling for several hundred
thousand pounds
an hour and you have an eight hour mini
series all of a sudden you've doubled
that team's revenue
in one fell swoop it's a sort of active
management it is very much bringing
special source
and and applying it to the asset
this isn't a punt either in recent years
streaming services have been flooded
with sports documentaries
for most teams it's a small part of the
business for wrexham
according to a letter sent to potential
sponsors it's a key part of the
commercial pitch
along with the opportunity to get your
name on the shirt the stadium and
working personally with two interested
hollywood stars
sports documentaries cost less than top
level games and have a longer shelf life
the biggest problem is whether it makes
compelling television
good tv requires troughs as well as
peaks meaning losses as well as wins
next thing i know rob mcelhaney gives me
a buzz and says i'd love to
pop up to santa barbara he like all of
us started to consume massive amounts of
netflix during lockdown and stumbled
across
a documentary series called sunderland
till i die
and he said i watched this and i was
enthralled
and less with the football action but
the people and the agony and the angst
and he
said i know these people this is
philadelphia this is every city
that has gone on tough times that has
been let down
by the one thing that can lift the
spirits which is their
their team as a result he said
i called ryan and said we need to buy a
football club just like i had to turn to
the experts to really understand
football to begin with
so too did ryan and rob see stars
they're just like us and they had the
perfect guy
someone who'd not only run a
championship club but who'd actually
lived in wrexham
wrexham i grew up there i played
football
there i played for wrexham school boys
played at the racecourse ground where
rex and play so
when i wasn't playing i watch wrexham
and in those days
they were a very good team uh playing in
the second division
of english football giant killers as
it's known so the big clubs would come
in the fa cup the knockout competition
and
most famously beat arsenal
fast forward to you know as recently as
as a year ago and the club had fallen
into
quite frankly disarray had gone into
administration bankruptcy
nolan please chip that now the situation
for wrexham fans was kind of win-win
they can't fall much further and in
their eyes american ownership
probably means climbing the ladder and
maybe even hitting the big time
but when foreign owners pick up a team
in part to use it as a vehicle for a
video series
it gives you a sense of how much the
game has changed football is a very
simple
virtuous cycle you make as much money as
you possibly can
you invest that on the pitch those
players
bring you victories when you win a lot
sponsors like that
and they will give you more money which
you then turn around
and spend on the pitch and you get even
better players
who win you league championships and
champions league trophies
and sponsors want to be a part of that
as well and they give you even money so
it's a classic virtuous cycle
ultimately what happens in the best
leagues in the world won't have that
much effect
on the grassroots kids will still go to
the park and play and they'll continue
to play
for years to come but the question
remains
will big business spoil the beautiful
game
in recent months a lot of chatter has
emerged about how the biggest clubs in
the world are trying to consolidate
power
and get a bigger slice of the pie for
themselves which raises another question
can english football survive this
americanization
i think if you went to ask almost any
football fan
do you like relegation and promotion
they will say yes
because it is actually what brings the
thrill to the game when people talk
about
football evoking such passion
partly because there's more at stake for
the club you know if you lose a game
you could be out of the top league for a
number of years and
and in the doldrums there's a move to
try to get the top labs
in a league which is always the same
members year in year out
it is a way of ensuring that those clubs
retain their value they have predictable
revenue
that will be recurring for the years to
come
and because it's at a european level
where they'll be playing against all the
other top clubs
uh they will attract a bigger
international fan base now
that might be at the detriment to the
detriment of the normal fan
everyday fan in their home city
for on a simple reason they may not be
able to travel to
munich or madrid or milan every other
week it's quite expensive and so
it's something that investors like but
fans on the whole really don't
the biggest fear of course is that you
lose fairy tales like leicester city
this is a team that rose from being in
the third tier of english football
to winning the whole thing in a span of
just seven years
at five thousand to one to win the
league that season
bookmakers had never paid out so much
but there are other types of fairy tales
maybe still to be written
who knows maybe we'll see wrexham in the
premier league before too long
so much for watching would love to hear
what you think about this and other
episodes
about the business of sports i'll be in
the comments section
can't wait to hear what you think
you